bonjour xavier moreau merci de répondre
à nos questions sur rt france avant
toute chose comment est ce que cet
événement est suivi cet exercice de
questions-réponses et suivies en russie
c'est un marronnier saluer tous les ans
à moscou mais c'est quelque chose qu'on
ne fait pas en france est-ce que ça
plaît aux russes c'est ce qui a pas trop
de langue de bois
oui non ça fait beaucoup pour us en fait
c'est à une conférence qui a été mise en
place en 2012 et c'était une manière
pour l'avenir poutine de reprendre la
main après les manifestations qui
avaient eu lieu fin 2020 2011 début 2012
et pour lui ça a été extrêmement
efficace puisque notamment il avait
obtenu un soutien populaire très marqués
face aux manifestants moscovite qui
était essentiellement ce qu'on appelle
ici là la créative des classes c'est à
dire ce qu'on appelle les bobos et
d'ailleurs il ya vu cette scène où on
voyait les ouvriers d'oural wagon mode
eux donc il ya fabricant de comme son
nom l'indiqué de wagons et de chars qui
proposait vadimir poutine qui sont dans
l'oural et qui proposait venir poutine
de venir à moscou pour pour le
débarrasser justement de ces
manifestants de la créative des classes
donc c'est un lien direct entre le
peuple russe et le président russe dans
lequel la dîmière poutine est très à
l'aise et où toutes les questions toutes
les questions peuvent être posées
même celles qui sont qui peut qui
pourrait le mettre en difficulté
beaucoup de questions sur la politique
intérieure mais nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est surtout la politique
extérieure et parmi les sujets évoqués
il ya l'ukraine le président russe n'a
pas fermé la porte notamment une
rencontre avec son homologue ukrainien
volodimir zielinski ce certaines
conditions savoir de quoi précisément
les deux hommes
pourront parler car selon vladimir
poutine qui a fait dirigé par des pays
extérieurs
que faut-il attendre sur ce dossier on
l'appelle deux semaines après le face à
face
poutine byden à genève avant le
rendez-vous buydens zielinski également
effectivement vladimir poutine a répondu
en fait une question qui lui demandait
pourquoi est-ce que l'ukraine n'est pas
classé parmi les pays hostiles à la
russie comme le sont les états unis et
la tchéquie et vladimir poutine a dit
qu'il faisait la différence entre les
autorités ukrainiennes et le peuple
ukrainien en répétant ce qu'il a dit à
plusieurs reprises ces dernières années
c'est à dire que les ukrainiens et les
russes sont un même peuple
il a même il a dit qu'il allait publier
leurs côtés des férus d'histoire il a
dit qu'il allait publier un article là
dessus qu'ils montrent que et bien les
peuple biélorusse mal aux russes donc
c'est l'ukrainien et grand'rue siens
selon la même source ou les trois
peuples qui descendent delà de la rousse
de kiev
donc en montrant bien que pour lui il
n'a rien contre eux contre le peuple
ukrainien
en revanche ce qu'il a dit effectivement
c'est qu' il veut bien rencontré le
président céline ski mais pour parler de
quoi
et là j'avais déjà défini sa par rapport
justement la guillotine ne veut plus
faire des rencontres qui ne servent à
rien comme ç'avait été par exemple la
rencontre de brégançon où en gros ça
vient faire de la publicité
à l'époque c'était pour l'analyse macro
et puis ça n'aboutit à rien donc ce
qu'il veut avec céline ski c'est un
véritable rencontre diplomatique comme
celles par exemple qu'il a eu avec paris
donne c'est à dire que on la prépare
pendant un mois on sait de quoi on va
parler on c'est en gros ce qui va en
sortir donc c'est arrêter de faire du
entre guillemets 2 parce qu'évidemment
pour poser lenski rencontrer vladimir
poutine sur un pied d'égalité
étant donné la baisse de son de sa cote
de popularité en ukraine ce serait ce
serait très bien mais vladimir poutine
ne veut pas le rencontrer pour ne rien
dire et surtout la balle est toujours
dans le camp de zielinski depuis 2019 ou
quand il ya eu la ruelle la réunion du
format normandie c'est à dire avec
l'allemagne la france la russie et
l'ukraine
zielinski s'est engagé à progresser sur
les accords de minsk et jusqu'à présent
il n'a rien fait on a même eu au
contraire assisté en début d'année une
tentative de
de provoquer militairement les
républiques de donetsk et de lougansk en
tous les cas il ya une réaction du
ministère des affaires étrangères de
l'ukraine à la déclaration de vladimir
poutine ce matin sur un seul peuple
les ukrainiens et les russes sont deux
peuples différents ils pourraient vivre
dans un esprit de bon voisinage si ce
n'était pas la russie qu'est ce que ça
vous évoque
si vous voulez c'est ce qu'on entend
c'est ce qu'on entend de chez les élites
ukrainienne mais c'est pas du tout de ce
que pensent les les ukrainiens alors ça
dépend des cas si vous dans la partie
est et sud de la russie si vous avez un
dessin aussi vous allez à kharkov et
bien sûr qu'ils se sentent russe
après si vous allez en ukraine centre à
l'autre de kiev
oui il ya une spécificité et si vous
allez totalement à l'ouest de l'ukraine
d'ailleurs vladimir poutine a rappelé en
disant que cette partie en galicie
volhynie qui a été intégrée à une époque
à la pologne et puis ensuite qui a été
intégrée à l'empiré austro hongrois puis
nous voilà pologne puis de nouveau c'est
ukraine qui a été créée artificiellement
par les bolchéviques tout ça a contribué
à séparer eu un peuple qui était le même
il ya mille ans et encore une fois ce
que disent les autorités ukrainiennes la
propagande ukrainienne on entend depuis
je dirais même pas depuis 2014 ou
quasiment depuis 30 ans le l'ancien
président koutchma avait écrit un livre
qui s'appelait il ya une dizaine
d'années qui s'appelait au grain et
aussi en ukrainien
l'ukraine n'est pas la russie
malheureusement c'est pas ce que pensent
sans doute plus de la moitié des
ukrainiens donc évidemment c'est à eux
que lanières poutine s'adresse et
d'ailleurs il sera de plus en plus
facile pour les ukrainiens d'obtenir la
citoyenneté russe et ça a déjà commencé
je change de sujet xavier moreau on a
évoqué donc le dossier ukrainien
vladimir poutine s'est exprimé également
sur son rapport avec des états unis
notamment à sec lundi vladimir poutine
et le président chinois xi jingping se
sont entretenus lyon notamment prolonger
le traité de bon voisinage entre moscou
et pékin
et ce alors que début juin on se
souvient il
g7 et les pays du g7 ont évoqué un front
commun face à la chine
et face à la russie à quoi est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre en termes de jeu
diplomatique mondiale ces prochains
jours entre entre ces différents blocs
alors que beaucoup appellent un
multilatéralisme
on l'a vu notamment encore hier avec
heiko maas a en italie
oui en effet l'avenir à d'ailleurs
souligné que en parité de pouvoir
d'achat
l'économie chinoise est désormais le pib
chinois est désormais 20% supérieur à
celui des etats unis
donc il est évident que les états unis
ont perdu leur leur place de première
économie dans le monde et ensuite du
point de vue militaire même s'ils ont un
outil militaire surdimensionnée avec un
budget militaire qui est supérieur à la
moitié de l'addition de tous les budgets
militaires en le monde
malgré tout et bien cette puissance
militaire ne leur donne pas la capacité
d'inquiéter ni la russie ni ni ni la
chine qui sont qui sont des puissances
nucléaires
et effectivement ce qu'a dit aussi être
intéressant d'ailleurs poutine c'est que
si byron a voulu rencontrer vladimir
poutine c'est à cause de la chine
pourquoi parce que vient la chine à de
nouvelles met en place de nouveaux
canaux commerciaux dont il ya les
fameuses routes de la soie donc des
routes terrestres qui sont les routes
qui sont les chemins de fer qui passe
principalement par la russie n'est mais
pas seulement il ya également les la
route maritime du nord qui permet en
passant par l'arctique et en longeant
les côtes russes de de rallier avec
quinze jours deux mois les ports de les
ports de la baltique à la chine est donc
effectivement dans la si la russie la
chine veut continuer son expansion
économique la russie est un partenaire
privilégié et cette position convient
tout à fait à la russie il est évident
que la chine même si on n'en a pas parlé
parce que saura jamais ce qui s'est
réellement dit ou pas pas tout de suite
le sera ce lien entre la chine et la
russie étaient au coeur de la discussion
avec joe biden est ce qu'ils voulaient
qu est ce qu il veut obtenir ce qu'il
voulait si d'obtenir de la russie
qu'elle reste en équilibre entre la
chine
et l'occident mais pour ça il faut que
l'occident est quelque chose
d'intéressant à proposer et pour
l'instant la seule chose que propose
aussi que l'occident c'est des sanctions
donc effectivement aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la balle est là encore des
occidentaux et de washington bien
entendu merci xavier moreau pour ce
décryptage je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur de ce tract paul centrale
analyse politico stratégiques